Guerry sick author of the book October
Surprise in the introduction you say
that a book such as this can only serve
as a cautionary tale why'd you write
that because that's exactly the way I
feel about it that you can't go back and
refight the election of 1980 you can't
charge bill Casey he's bid you can't
really do much of anything about it
except to warn people that this sort of
thing goes on and that they should watch
out for it
and I think that that's the important
part of the book it obviously has
political significance and other things
but fundamentally it's to warn people
that if the democratic process is going
to work you have to be careful in the
event that somebody's been hiding under
a rock over the last couple months this
book is about what this book is about
the attempt by the Reagan Bush campaign
to meet with the Iranians and delay the
release of the American hostages until
after the election and have them
delivered to Ronald Reagan instead of
Jimmy Carter to try to affect the
outcome of the election in 1980 why did
you write it it's an easy question and
it's a long answer I didn't know I was
going to write this book
even three years ago when I started
doing the research I I sent out to write
a book about the Reagan administration's
involvement with Iran and I thought that
I was going to deal primarily with the
iran-contra affair as time went along I
started working on the book and I
decided that to to really talk about the
iran-contra affair and to talk about the
Reagan dealings with Iran you had to
look at what happened in 1980 that was
where it all began and as I started
doing the research on this and I thought
that would be rather quick and easy I
found that that was a story in itself
and it just got bigger and bigger until
finally I had to make a decision do I go
ahead and write the book I intended to
write or do I write something else and I
finally decided I had to go ahead and
write this other book so this is a this
is a
steak this was never intended to happen
I noticed in the you know the
introduction to closed that you signed
this off of September of 1990 this is
only a couple months later how did this
book come out so fast it really is
pretty amazing
I wrote a an article an op-ed article
for the Washington for the New York
Times in April April 15th 1991 and it
attracted a good deal of attention and
Random House came to me in May and said
they would like to do the book and so in
mid-may we sat down and had a discussion
about what I could do unfortunately I
had not written the book before I wrote
the article I should have of course a
terrible mistake
and I so they said okay how quickly can
you write this book and I took a very
deep breath and I said August and they
said alright we'll lay down a schedule
and we will go ahead and plan for
production and everything else to get
the book out in January and so I started
writing furiously I disappeared from
sight from May 15th until literally the
end of August and finally I surfaced
again with the full manuscript I gave it
to the people at Random House times
books they gave me two superb editors
who took the book and spent about two
weeks tearing it apart and putting it
back together again
and we had negotiations over that and
when I signed off on that in September
that was when we had put the final
touches on that manuscript but even
after that we went ahead making changes
and fixes into October and then they put
it straight into the press it came out
and literally from was out then on
November 11th actually the first books
came off the press I actually held one
in my hand on November 6th which it was
really only a month after we had stopped
making final changes to the thing so
it's an extraordinary piece of work and
they clearly decided to go quickly
because
the story keeps moving and they didn't
want a lot of the story to get away
before the book came out and it turned
out the timing was really remarkable did
you actually write it yourself
I certainly did every word what do you
do for a living right where's home
I live in Manhattan have an apartment I
have been I was gainfully employed up
until about three or four years ago when
my kids graduated from college and I
decided that since I've been spending
most of my money on their very expensive
educational habits
I was now free to either start
accumulating some of that money or to do
without it and I decided to do without
it I will go to work for myself
researching writing and doing what I
wanted to do I never made a better
decision in my life I have a little tiny
study about the size of this table in my
home I go in I have my computer there
the world's shortest commute from the
bedroom to my little study and that's
where I work I've got a modem I've got a
telephone I've got a fax machine I've
got everything I need I can communicate
with the rest of the world and I sit I
research I write and I have a very good
time and do you work and for any other
institution yeah I'm an adjunct
professor of Middle East politics of
Columbia and that this semester means
I'm teaching a class once a week is this
a political book in other words did
maybe I can ask it better did this book
come out because you want to affect the
process or did you come out because you
want to make money well I never have any
objection to making money that's
perfectly acceptable and I think any
author that says they don't want to make
money on their book has got to be crazy
but I wrote it no I was in the White
House when this happened when the
election of 1980 took place and I had a
chance to witness these things firsthand
I wrote another book called all fall
down about the Iranian Revolution and
the hostage crisis and the way I the way
it looked from my vantage point and when
I started going through this again what
I had to do in this book was actually to
go back and re-examine
a whole body of history that I thought I
had known and it was like tearing the
pea off an onion you kept pulling it
back and saying wait a minute
I thought I knew what happened at that
time and then deciding discovering that
in fact you'd only known part of the
story so it was a discovery process it
was a mystery story I'm an analyst by
vocation I spent 24 years in the Navy as
a intelligence analyst naval
intelligence and I ended up as a Navy
captain and spent a lot of my life in
fact all of my life for all practical
purposes amidst in one way or another
putting together complex puzzles this is
perhaps the most complex puzzle I'd ever
run into and so there was a real
challenge at doing this and then finally
as I got into the material and began and
came to a you know to have a serious
grasp of this mass of stuff I think I
felt a certain obligation if people
carry out this kind of nefarious
political activity they get away with it
and they win elections and nobody ever
calls them on it what that means who the
democratic system is we're going to have
more of that they're going to do it
again and the word in Washington among
the insiders who know these things will
be this works try it you'll like it
so I felt that the least I could do was
to put the thing out in public and say
here it is here's the evidence that's
persuaded me see if it'll persuade you
and if so at least holding that up as a
warning signal to other people to say
wait a minute maybe you can't get away
with the next time as you know I've got
them right here there have been a couple
of publications that have worked this
whole theory over pretty good one of
them is a cover story and the November
18th New Republic camera is kind of far
away we'll get up closer so you can see
what this cover looks like people
probably seen this understand the
question is what October surprise and
inside this is written by
Steve Emerson and Jesse Furman let me
just read one paragraph almost every
primary source cited by sick or
frontline has been indicted or was the
subject of a federal investigation prior
to claiming to be a participant in the
October Surprise finally evidence we
have uncovered shows that William Casey
and George Bush could not have been
present at the meetings alleged by the
sources first of all remember that Steve
Emerson wrote that piece although it
says November 18th on the cover in the
peculiar world of magazine publishing in
fact it was published a full week before
my book came out on the 11th so it was
in I read it a week before and Emerson
interviewed me for this and I said look
my my book is going to deal with these
issues in some detail and the use of
sources that you're alleging in this
article simply aren't true he chose not
to use my information and not to wait
for the book so this was written before
the book came out and does not in any
way reflect what I've done in the book
because he didn't know what I was doing
in the book other than what I just told
him in the interview as a result the
article is kind of odd in a sense
because what it does is it creates a
sort of hypothetical conspiracy theorist
who believes in this story and says here
is this mythical individual and if they
believe in this they must believe in the
Tooth Fairy because there's this and
there's that in it and it sets up a
whole array of straw men and then knocks
them down but as I told Steve in our
interview before he published this many
of the sources the first five or six
pages of this article are devoted to one
source Richard brenneke I don't use him
at all and in fact with all due modesty
I believe that I debunked Richard
Rennick II more effectively than Steve
Emerson does so this debunking effort I
think
as you know slightly misguided and off
the mark but the charge in there about
the sources indicate that Casey could
not possibly have been in Madrid are
just are just simply false they in
Emerson had talked to a guy in London
who said that Casey was at a conference
we had known the case he was at a
conference in London and he was there
for about a day and a half and he you
know the records are a little fuzzy but
let's call it a day and a half that he
was in London he was missing for four to
five days he'd left the states and on
the on Friday or Saturday night came
back on Wednesday and are you talking
about so in case the audience had Oh
October of 1980 this is this is this is
July of 1980 July of nineteen that's
right and the allegation that I make is
that in Vermont the source that I talked
to who was an eyewitness who was there
at the meetings said that Casey was in
Madrid during this period of time and we
had actually traced Casey's movements
outside the country and nobody had ever
admitted the case he was outside the
country in Madrid meeting with that he
was in the Madrid meeting with an
Iranian representative Magda Karoubi who
at the time was an associate of
Khomeini's today he is the Speaker of
the modulus the Parliament in Iran doing
what making a deal but this was where in
fact the deal began that resulted in the
delay of the hostages and the release of
the hostages to the Reagan
administration so my source had talked
about this and we had traced Casey out
of the country and they say well he was
in London he was in London there's
absolutely no doubt about he was in
London for a day and a half all day
Monday and half of Tuesday he left on
Friday or Saturday he didn't get back in
till Wednesday
there was plenty of time Madrid is 30
minutes I mean it's 90 minutes from from
London by plane and was used routinely
as a shuttle point to go back and forth
to Madrid for these people that were
operating on this operation so I just
don't agree with the article at all and
I I do wish that the article that and
the Newsweek
article had waited until after the book
came out so that they could have in fact
dealt with what I said
not with this mythical individual who
supposedly is believer in a conspiracy
theory I don't identify with the
individual that they create and seize
the cover now of making of a myth the
October Surprise which is also a
debunking of your book exactly in fact
the two articles came out the same day
and are really quite similar okay
you know a lot of people are accusing
you all kinds of things in writing this
book let's go back to these articles and
I want to ask you what's the motive of
the New Republic which is owned by Marty
parrots and what's the in your opinion
the motive of Newsweek which is owned by
The Washington Post company I don't
think it's my business to examine their
motives they are examining mine
they say I'm a dupe that I've been taken
to the cleaners by these people that
they think that I'm being used for
political purposes and so forth I'm not
going to all I can say is that the
articles came out together quite
somewhere one week and as far as I know
they didn't work on these things
together well I take that back in fact
the Newsweek article refers to the two
Emerson's article and so forth so they
were in contact with each other before
this time and they use exactly the same
pieces of evidence they've talked to the
same people and they go about it in very
much the same way presumably their
motive is that they didn't believe the
story I you know I find it difficult to
believe in it the part that really
bothers me about both of these stories
is that if you look at the end of the
Newsweek story it ends up saying that
maybe this whole thing began with a big
misunderstanding and what if the people
that were talking in London to the
American representative the the Carter
representative thought they were really
talking to the Republicans and this was
all just a case of mistaken identity
I mean this is just wildly speculative I
was in the government at the time I know
about the meeting
that went on with the American
representative him it definitely there
was no case of mistaken identity and I
told them that also but they seemed to
like this theory and they ran with it
and I honestly don't understand what was
going on here let me ask you this and
maybe you don't want to deal with Marty
parrots is an avowed scientist he
believes very strong in the State of
Israel he set it on this network any
suspicion that one of the reasons they
would pick this line is because one of
the things you accuse Israel of doing is
being an intermediary in the weapons
well it's a legitimate question and
again I can't examine their motives it
is true that this book is not very
flattering to Israel and that I would
anticipate that that people who feel
strongly that way would feel a need but
as I say the articles in both cases are
not really directed at the book as much
as they are at the the general story
these came out before they either one
neither one of them claimed that they
actually have read this book or are
responding to what it says they're
simply saying in advance what what they
think is going to happen it may in fact
be more of a reaction in some respects
to the Sai Hirsch book that had come out
just a few weeks earlier which uses one
of these sayings one of the same sources
that I do Arab in minashi who is a
former Israeli intelligence operative
and who plays a prominent role in my
book as well as inside Hirsch's book and
he is saying things that the Israelis
are very very unhappy about so the fact
that that well for instance that that
Steve Emerson got access to personnel
records from the Intelligence Division
in Iran in Israel that personnel records
have area been minashi which nobody else
had been able to lay their hands on
suggests that he had at least the
Israelis were prepared to cooperate with
him on this when he interviewed me he
was in Israel that's where he was doing
his research and that's where he called
me to do the the interview did you sense
by the way when Steve Emerson called you
that he was
come out against what oh yes oh yes I
mean it was very clear no him I'd known
him we had we had talked various times
in the past I was aware of various
stories that he had done and researched
it then we had not known each other well
instead passing how about and then this
may be really stretching things but news
weeks on by The Washington Post company
and you first wrote your article in The
New York Times on April the 15th this
year where you laid all this out is
there any sense that there's a
competitive thing here the Washington
Post and again I have no reason to
believe that the Washington Post
inspired them to do this no I really
don't think that was that was the issue
The Washington Post however has been
quite hostile to this story and from the
very beginning as has not been very
receptive to the idea and again I can't
explain the motives of that either
but my impression is that that John
Barry the chief reporter who did this
once he got the information about Casey
in London he quit looking and quit
thinking that there was anything else to
look for that had that disproved
everything and John Berry's British he
has British that's correct
so his connection was in Britain for the
information that he he's he's British
but he works in United States now but it
was his information was his source
British his source was British as a
matter of fact yes and mr. Chadwick at
the Royal Army Medical College for the
Royal War Museum was the person who
provided the information about Casey
being in in London and you know we had
known about Casey being in London before
we I in my book there's a photograph of
Casey in London I mean and I died that
was put out before these articles were
written so the fact that Casey was in
London certainly didn't come as a
surprise to me it was in the book it was
described and there's a picture of Casey
you know at the during this conference
that he was holding in London so that
didn't come as a as a surprise to me at
all but there's a sense that once that
information was found
once that was lowkey
did that that John Barry's simply
decided that everything about this story
was false and I think they just didn't
look hard enough because that in my view
does not mean that this could not have
taken place it there is a and you know I
must say maybe I shouldn't say this but
in order to understand this story
you've got to read it maybe that's not
fair in other words to understand the
anchors I tried to figure out how am I
going to ask you questions about well
probably it really is true you know that
and that in one sense is why I wrote it
because dealing with this subject among
the people that work with it there's a
kind of shorthand you know Hashemi says
this and you know what that's talking
about it you know the first Madrid
meeting this happened and so and you go
on and on but the other for a normal
reader for a normal even well-informed
individual it's impossible to know what
this shorthand is talking about and you
need some kind of a god this book among
other things is an attempt to create a
guide that will easily take a reader
through this very complex story and I
hope show why what the motives would be
of the individuals involved what the
evidence is does it now exists something
about the sources who they are where
they come from what their background is
why they would or would not have access
to certain information and that is a so
I hope that the book will at least lift
the level of discourse so that anybody
who wants to talk about this subject in
the future at least will have a sort of
set of guide path guideposts set out for
them that you can then know at least
what the baseline of information is and
can can go on from there let me talk
about the journalism of this whole thing
with you if we can it seems like some
different people chosen up sides on this
yes there it's really true how about the
networks I notice on page 236 you say
three other journalists were
particularly generous and helpful then
you mentioned Terra Sun and shine those
of ABC TV's Nightline took an early
interest in the story introduced me to
some key sources and with her superb
team of researchers broke several parts
of the story did they then have an
once they got to working with you Tara
had started working on this story before
I ever met her and had done a lot of
independent research one of the
interesting things about working on this
story was that I was working on my own I
don't I don't have a research staff I
don't even have a secretary it's just me
and I go do my thing and a lot of the
other reporters and other people who had
become interested in this story over
time for one reason or another mostly
because they thought there was really
something there and it had been
overlooked and covered up and that it
needed a lot more digging those
reporters were often working on their
own time they had very little
institutional support they had no
bureaus to draw on they had no research
support for the most part but they were
interested and we didn't have the luxury
of fighting among ourselves in terms of
you know I go first and I'm gonna get
this scoop but basically everybody that
was involved in the story was interested
in the story and was interested in
getting it out and was interested in
finding out what really happened and it
was a rare an unusual set of
circumstances but it was a pleasure of
absolute joy to work on the story from
that point of view that you didn't have
to feel that somebody was just milking
you and they were going to run off and
and publish behind your back or they
were going to be telling stories about
you or something else it was a good
group a smart group and a lot of and we
did pursue this thing sharing
information among ourselves helping each
other out
sharing sources if I suddenly found that
that there was a lead out on the West
Coast someplace that I couldn't pursue
there was a guy that I worked with out
on the west coast I would call and say
hey if you have a chance could you talk
to so-and-so and that he would do that
and call me back and send me a
transcript of the interview or say
there's nothing there and so forth we
shared among ourselves so Tara was one
of the people who I shared information
with and others are named in the book as
well does that mean she has a stake in
it I mean that skyline has a stake in it
I don't think so
it meant that Nightline was ahead of the
game
they had more information faster than
any of the other networks and you know
if there is a professional jealousy
there I think that maybe one of the
sources of it we ever on the ABC payroll
for this I've not been on any payroll of
any organization for this except for the
20th century fund which provided me a
grant to do this book now I have not
worked as a consultant for ABC ever
who's the 20th century fund 20th century
fund is a nonprofit organization in in
New York which has been around for many
years and what they specialize in is
giving grants to into for single author
books on policy issues and they've been
doing it for years hiding political no
they're not
they had a partisan no they cover the
waterfront you think that they're we're
interested in your book because they
knew that the slant it would take they
the proposal that I wrote for them was
not for this book it was for a much more
general book that was really examining
the relationship between the Reagan
administration and Iran so they didn't
they couldn't have known what they were
going to get and what I did was about
the fall of 1989 maybe 90 I went back to
them and I said look I gave you a
proposal I promised to write you a
certain kind of a book and I had a
chapter outline and everything I said
I'm not gonna write that book right now
I said you don't owe me a thing and I
said if you want me to I'm gonna just
put that aside for the moment and I'll
come back and write that book for you
later I owe it to you and I'm forgetting
to do that the book that I'm going to
write is going to be very controversial
very messy and it's likely to get
certainly me in trouble but it could get
you in trouble too and you're quite free
to just drop out at this point tell me
to go off and do my own thing and then
when I come back we can do this other
book together they thought seriously
about that and said go ahead and write
it and gave me full support to continue
pursuing the subject and they don't
necessarily endorse it I mean in the
sense of saying that this is their
thesis
but they thought that it was an
important policy issue and it needed to
be looked at and that's after all what
they were there for and Richard Liang
the president of the foundation is I
just think a terrific guy and I had
great support to them all the way
through they didn't have to do this and
it's a risky thing for them as well for
any nonprofit institution but they took
it where did they get their money
it's an endowment it was given to them I
wish I knew the name of their founder
they all shoot me for not being able to
say that publicly but some years ago a
gentleman very wealthy gave the money
for this very purpose and the
institution has been going on for I
don't know how many years are you aware
of any other projects that they've
involved in that the audience might be
familiar with gee I wish I had done a
little more homework I mean I I am aware
I mean they've got they put out the I
think you know eight books or more a
year I shouldn't be talking just off the
cuff like this because I really haven't
done the research but they they put out
a it's a considerable range of books
that they publish every year what they
do is they take an author on just as if
they were giving him an advance and say
we give you so much time you write a
book for us and when they get the book
they own it they take the book and then
they go to the publishers and say just
as if they this is if they were agent
almost and try to place the book if they
can't place the book then they become a
publisher and they publish the book
themselves but they publish a wide range
of things on European policy on Social
Security on healthcare on foreign policy
most of its domestic policy though most
of their books focus on domestic policy
rather than on foreign policy but there
are a number of foreign policy books is
this the only book you've done for them
yes
your front-line connection there's a Bob
Perry I believe Bob Perry and Robert
Ross see the same Bob Perry that used to
be with Newsweek that's correct
who's done our show many times here the
reason I bring that up it's interesting
had he still been with Newsweek he might
have been involved in this this other
that's right story
Bob Perry has been interested in the
story for a long long time and he's been
working on it on his own he couldn't get
support that means weak in fact to work
on this story and that's now he's been
working on it on his own freelancing and
then he proposed as I understand it he
proposed this idea of a special to PBS
and hooked up with Robert Ross who is a
television producer who also speaks
Persian - turns out which is very
convenient in this particular thing and
who lived in Iran for a while and they
set to work the two of them to go out
and and do a television version of what
I was doing basically in print let me
this may sound like it's not all that
important but it it just seems to be a
thread through all this going back to
the Newsweek piece I found it
interesting that John Murray's piece led
off by saying the outlet was hardly
prestigious this is for the first part
of this whole story the executive
Intelligence Review which is a LaRouche
publication did you read that
I read the article the article but then
it says the next I mean this is when
this I read the Newsweek article article
then they points out that when the story
got his next boost in April of 87 who
was in the Miami Herald and then it
moves from there is that nobody paid
much attention to it then and then it
moved the herald story didn't get much
played but when bani-sadr next spoke to
Flora lewis of the New York Times in
August of 87 the story grew the only
reason I mentioned this is that you had
access to the op-ed page of the New York
Times on April the 15th of this year and
then the front line story ran what the
next day that's correct
how does all this work man and and why
is it meaning of this but no but and why
isn't all of a sudden in order to get
the attention I had to get to the New
York Times first what is this what's the
well you know it's a it's an interesting
point because inevitably in a
complicated or highly controversial
political issue but the time the story
breaks in a big way and comes to a lot
of people's attention it has already
been covered by the alternative media
that's not a long unusual that
alternative presses smaller in these
papers are covering these stories doing
the real investigative reporting and
very frequently the the big newspapers
are busy reporting sort of what is
happening sort of recording history
whereas the littler presses are hungry
they're enthusiastic and they're
energetic and they're out there digging
like crazy and they're coming up with
stuff some of it bad and some of it very
good and usually you'll find that the
origin of a story for instance the
inslaw story would not we probably
better not get into that a whole a whole
nother can of worms but any big story
that you look at often there was a
subterranean press that that covered it
first and some reporters that were out
there digging who often in the end don't
get full credit for what they do this is
simply another example that people were
out there digging around and the
mainstream press are very slow to pick
up on these things I've found the
mainstream press to be really quite
timid in dealing with a tough political
issue one that really goes to the bone
that isn't just sort of cosmetic a
little scandal somebody misusing funds
somebody's sleeping with somebody else
that has you know in the political arena
but really goes to the heart of the
thing maybe that's what it means to be
mainstream is that you're extremely
conservative about making accusations or
carrying things on so how did I get to
the what is your question how did I get
to the the op-ed page of the New York
Times or why didn't they buy your people
why did they buy my piece well the way
it happened was
that in the spring of 1990 a an editor
at the op-ed page of the New York Times
called me up and said I've been hearing
about this October Surprise theory and
she said she thought there was quite a
story there and if it was real it was
one of the biggest stories of the decade
of all time and she thought it really
ought to be looked at and wonder what I
was doing I said I am working on it she
knew that I was working on it she said
well would you write something for us on
the thing I said no no I'm definitely
not ready yet that I've done a lot of
research but I'm nowhere near ready to
to write the story there's just so much
that I don't know and I'm missing
she said well let's stay in touch and I
said she said do you have anybody else
to suggest and I suggested two or three
other people that I said they could
contact that might be willing to write a
story form she called me back and said
well let's stay in touch on this thing
now there's no immediate rush on the
thing so we did for a year and we would
talk every month or two and she would
say you know how are you doing I'd say
well I'm making some progress are you
ready to write and I'd say no and that
was that finally in the spring of from
January 1991 on the tempo of this really
picked up very dramatically we had a
bunch of new sources new things were
coming together Bob Perry and Robert
Ross had been out scouring territory
they had new interview material I had
interviewed John sheet Hashemi and he'd
given me a whole new dimension of this
story carrying it on to Madrid and the
meetings with Karoubi
and there was a sense of momentum and
even excitement about the way the story
was was developing suddenly after all
this time of grubbing around with little
tiny details suddenly there was a modest
breakthrough and so they said their
documentary was getting put together and
they were getting ready to go on the air
with it and we agreed very clearly that
it probably would be very useful to have
something in print
to go along with the television show so
I figured you know at some point I'm
gonna have to write about this and this
seems to be the moment to do it because
we now had all of this together so I
called my friend at the op-ed page and I
said I'm ready are you ready and she
said let's see what you've got so I
wrote him a piece but I thought was
three times too long but I said it's
hard to compress this story into a few
sentences and I said take a look at it
and see if you think you can edit it
down to make something out of it they
thought about it for several days called
me back and said we're prepared to go
with it but we needed to be a little
longer got it have answers to this and
that and then we went into an intensive
editing phase word by word phrase by
phrase that went on for I've forgotten
most seemed like a good part of a week
they knew that front line was coming out
on Tuesday and the New York Times not
wanting to be scooped said will make
room for it on Monday and much to my
amazement gave me almost the entire
op-ed page for this article it was
amazing and it frontline care I mean
they liked the idea you're gonna hit the
New York Times first I think we had
mixed emotions on one hand I think they
were happy to have a mainstream
publication coming out with the same
story at the same time they were and it
meant real credibility and real punch to
to the story it got people's attention
and I think a lot of people looked at
the frontline story that would not have
I mentioned it in my in the op-ed page
so I mean so the op-ed piece mentions
the fact that frontline is going to be
doing this the next day on the other
hand like all journalists I think there
were those who thought it would be great
if we were out there first and that's
but I
I can't speak for frontline and I
thought they were basically pretty happy
with the result they got they got
tremendous numbers on that show in terms
of listeners tuning in on the last page
where you sign off and in your book you
make this day Barbara Honaker deserve a
special mention why well as I said in
the when to read on from there that I
didn't agree with Barbara on many many
issues we didn't work together at all
she was not part of this little group
that worked together the Barbara Honaker
wrote a book also called October
Surprise not only how could he do that
there's absolutely you can have 15 books
by the same name the same year if you
want to this but you can't copyright a
book title and in fact there often are
two or three book by the same title that
was that was an editorial decision on
the ground that this phrase has come to
simply represent this story and they're
trying to come up with a more elegant
title in effect people would know what
they were talking about and this at
least somebody looked at that cover they
know what the book is about it's not its
truth in advertising there's nothing
else but any case she had written the
book that came out in 1989 called
October Surprise I disagreed with many
of the things in that book but she had
been absolutely dogged in her pursuit of
this story and she had uncovered a
number of sources and uncovered an
amount of information and kept the story
alive at a time when absolutely nobody
believed in it at all
so I thought that at a minimum she
deserved credit for the work that she
has done for which in many cases she is
not guiding got much appreciation even
from me so this was I'm not sure it's
fair to ask you this but why is it that
the executive Intelligence Review of
LaRouche that publication was just kind
of cast aside Barbara honaker's book was
even made fun of by people and then all
of a sudden Gary SiC is bought by the
New York Times and frontline and your
book is
out there well maybe it's not a fair
question to ask me because you need to
ask somebody else why they did that
let's face it I'm a fairly mainstream
person I was a retired Navy captain
24 years of Navy intelligence work I was
in the Defense Department for a number
of years I was in the White House for
six years I worked the three different
presidents in the White House I got out
I worked for a very conservative
organization I mean I worked for the the
for the Ford Foundation doing program
work for them I had done work on the
Middle East and I had you know and so
forth it's a it's a very sort of
conservative mainstream kind of it's not
necessarily a routine kind of CV but it
it is at least one that people can look
at and say well gee this this guy at
least is not a crazy coming out of left
field and I did have I had written for
The New York Times before I'd written I
don't know three or four different op-ed
pieces for them at various times in the
past I'd also written for the Washington
Post and I had done commentary on
national television at the time of the
Gulf War and you know I have done a lot
of work so my name was known to a lot of
people and I think that people who would
have said that's ludicrous that story is
unbelievable
I will have nothing to do with it if
they said you know if he's buying this
maybe just maybe it deserves another
look just to see and I think there was a
sort of mixture there in the end who
knows what what the outcome of this will
be but initially it seems to me that was
the that was what and that's what
motivated people to to give me if you
like a second reading getting back to
the the premise of the book on page 146
you say none of the principles involved
have ever spoken publicly about what
happened and there will never be a full
account of the discussions until that
happens and on the same page you
in this meeting there were six Israelis
16 Iranians in 12 Americans why haven't
any of those people spoken up well and
have my socks I said I said principles
because some of the people there have in
fact spoken up and very few of them very
very few I have tried very hard to talk
to specific individuals who had reason
either to know what was going on or to
have been there in my view this was a
covert political action covert actions
are done in secrecy people are pledged
to keep their mouth shut and for the
most part they do people take those
pledges very seriously
partly because they take a sort of
secrecy oath but beyond that they know
that they're going to be implicated in
the thing so they have every reason in
the world to keep their mouth shut
unless as some of the people who have
served as sources for this they really
have nothing left to lose they've been
indicted they're in trouble they feel
that they've been deserted by the people
that they worked with or they were in
very marginal characters who really had
no part in the major part of the thing
and so you get a little piece of the
puzzle so it's not surprising that the
sources that show up for this are not
Boy Scouts and Sunday School teachers I
mean that's not the kind of people that
they use for the thing and those are not
the kind of people that are now ready to
go public the principles I think have
not talked and how my feeling is the
only way you're ever going to get the
principles to talk and even that is not
going to be easy is with some kind of
congressional investigation that has
subpoena power and that is that is the
necessary element to get beyond this
that doesn't mean that you solve all of
your problems immediately but it does
mean at least you're in a position to
begin dealing with them where did you
grow up Kansas I was born in Russell
Kansas the same hometown as Bob Dole and
Arlen Specter as a matter of fact our
grew up there and went to high school
reading the same class no neither one of
them we didn't know each other in
Russell none of the three of us did but
I think it's kind of interesting this
little town of 6,000 people right out on
the bear plains of Kansas it's a lovely
spot and I my mother the book is
dedicated to my mother and I and I make
a point of getting out to Kansas was
often as I can and I always enjoy going
back but it's a tiny little town and I
went to the University of Kansas and
when and basically a by whole life there
and only later on
did I leave I the Navy provided my
mobility I guess to to leave Kansas and
would you study I was a French major in
college French literature as a matter of
fact I my specialty was 19th century
French poetry and 19th and early 20th
century most of which I've now forgotten
though not the French I after college I
got a fellowship and went to France for
a year lived with the French family
again studied literature but mostly
studied France I traveled around for a
year and then went into the Navy and
went to the Middle East a lot of time in
the Persian Gulf North Africa in the
Mediterranean what was your first year
in the Navy my first year in the Navy
was in the flagship in the Persian Gulf
what year 1958 and did you get
interested in the Middle East before did
you ask for that ask for that well what
I asked for
I was interested in intelligence work
because I it appealed to me because this
sort of putting puzzles together was
something that I really enjoyed doing
and I thought I would enjoy the work and
that was the only place that there was
an intelligence job available when when
I was assigned to there to the flagship
and
Persian Gulf I didn't know where the
Persian Gulf was I had to get out of map
and and find out where it was and I had
a great geography lesson in a year of
sailing around the Indian Ocean and
Persian Gulf places that were
wonderfully exotic and colorful and I
know in a sense for a small-town boy
from from Kansas it was sort of join the
Navy and see the world and I've seen an
awful part of the world where did you go
after that first year from the Persian
Gulf
I went curiously enough for period in
Paris with some language training and
then went down to Morocco and was
working in the there was a naval
installation a Navy base in Morocco that
put out a monthly magazine on political
events in the Middle East and so I spent
it was like up like a year of being a
reporter on a magazine and I learned a
lot about the Middle East and of course
that year read a lot and wrote a lot and
I enjoyed writing it was a great joy to
be able to turn out articles every two
weeks or something like that and what
are you coming on to be a full
lieutenant pretty soon at that point I
was I guess I was I made lieutenant I
guess while I was while I was in Morocco
where from there well then I went up had
a wonderful I got married while I was in
Morocco and my wife had been at Kansas
University with me and we went back got
married and then traveled through France
for a wonderful month and then came back
to the States and I had a series of
assignments in in Washington I went to
the Naval Intelligence School in here in
Washington and then later went out to
Fort Meade Maryland and was watching
Soviet missiles and naval activities
from that vantage point and then went
off to Cairo is the assistant naval
attache
I was in Cairo from 65 to 67 was there
at the beginning of the arab-israeli war
the six-day war I watched it from the
other end the receiving end and stand on
the roof of the embassy in Cairo and
watch the Israeli planes coming in to
hit the desert sites yeah literally
within sight flying around on the edge
the outskirts of the city
shrapnel falling on your head from
overseer from above as they were firing
off flak guns trying to knock down these
airplanes and made uh I was in one of
the people that was involved in setting
up the evacuation of Americans from from
Egypt drove down to Cairo and tried to
organize an evacuation and very exciting
period of time I loved Egypt I still do
and have been back a few times since
that time my daughter was born in Egypt
how many kids to have a son and a
daughter after Cairo what in the Navy
Cairo I came back W we were evacuated
from there spent a short time in Greece
and ended up in Italy with the sixth
fleet and again was stationed in Naples
loved Italy and my daughter loved it so
much that she's gone back and she now
lives in Italy become an Italian
actually she's her Italian is just
perfect we left there came back I went
to the Naval War College and then after
that I got a master's degree in
international relations while I was at
the War College and then went to
Colombia that the Navy has this
wonderful program that a few people a
year are funded to get PhDs and I was
lucky enough to be one of those and went
to Colombia for three years did all the
coursework in the dissertation finished
my PhD came down to Washington I wrote
my my dissertation on the notion great
power politics in the Indian Ocean and
that got me a job in the office of the
Secretary of Defense working on the
Persian Gulf and Indian Ocean issues
what year is this now that was in 1973
to 76 and the secretary defense is well
now Larry James Schlesinger was
James Schlesinger camión Hall I was
there that would basically Schlessinger
time
that's the guy I worked for most there
were there were other people before but
it was really Schlesinger that was the I
wrote some stuff for him and was
involved with with him but he had
commander at this point in the Navy yep
I was a commander at that time yeah
that's right and then went from there
because of my work in that in the
Secretary of Defense's circle system of
the security affairs I got to know a
number of people in the White House in
the National Security Council and when
President Ford was facing election as
often happens people jump ship they get
out while they're rolodex is still hot
and go to work for a consulting firm or
something and then after the election
people flood back in again and they're
always a lot of holes in over there in
the White House staff during that last
year or so six months to a year and so I
was invited to come over to the NSC
staff I thought that's a pretty bad
offer I'll go over there work for six
months it kicked out when the new people
come in whichever way the election goes
and then I'll be out of a job and I'll
have to go scrambling but I did it
anyway I thought I thought it would be a
great place to watch an election from
and it turned out to be a great place to
watch the election from the Carter
people came in after the election I
thought I would be sent back over to the
Department of Defense and they said stay
on it captain yet I was not but I was
then in before the end of the Carter
Administration I was promoted to captain
and that's the rank you left the Navy
what's the right Kartha maybe you're on
the NSC staff how many people are on the
staff at that point about so I recalled
around 50 professionals it's pretty
small you write in the conclusion
although I was a Democrat I had served
nearly half of my career under
Republican presidents why did you feel
the need to put that in the book because
I know that I'm going to be accused of
political partisanship people are going
to say this is a political hatchet job
you're just going after George Bush you
want to embarrass him it's a political
season etc and there's no way I can
avoid that
I mean I know that that charge is going
to go with it
the way I actually got into this book
though was not a carefully plotted event
but it does come at a political time it
is going to be seen as a political
document and so I at least want to make
my position clear I mean that this is
where I am and I have always been a
Democrat and though I've never worked in
political campaigns I've never been a an
activist and I think most people these
until this book came out probably
regarded me is generally nonpartisan I'd
never really participated in partisan
political activities this book is likely
to be used in a partisan way it's not
written in a partisan way but it's
likely to be used in a partisan way and
there's really nothing I can do about
that did you find many Democrats in the
Navy and in the officer corps we didn't
talk politics
seriously no we really didn't talk
politics very much and I honestly
couldn't answer your question I mean I I
I know that some people were Democrats
and some people Republicans but to say
did you meet a lot of them I simply
didn't identify people that I work with
as Republicans or Democrats you say in
the book and I know that I can find the
there's a line here and you know what
I'm talking about where you say that you
oh he said I would not be human if I did
not confess that I have at one time or
another awakened in the middle of the
night with the thought what if all these
people are lying to me is it possible
that all these accounts are themselves a
conspiracy of lies why did you put that
because it's true you can't work on a
story this big this complicated in this
dangerous dangerous to your own
professional career and to your own
reputation without asking yourself that
question and I must say that I've
answered that question to my own
satisfaction that I when I finally
decided that I was going to write this
book and in the course of writing the
book I believe that the degree of the
number of coincidences that occurred in
this story that if you are going to show
that this was a conspiracy of Lies you
have to invent another massive
conspiracy theory to say that all of
these people have been secretly
exchanging information among themselves
that they've got some motive which is
not easy to determine why they would all
be going to this immense effort to put
out this story it's not clear that any
of them are benefiting from it in fact
many of them have been really seriously
hurt by the story and the fact that it
came out personally vilified you know
they've lost jobs in many cases lost
money and in some cases have been
threatened with court cases I mean
Richard brenneke was subjected to a
perjury trial I mean it's not clear that
they had much to gain from doing this
but you have to come up with a theory
what do they all have to gain how was it
all put together how were these people
planted Jamshid Hacha me Francis my the
source that I used probably as much as
anyone in the book he didn't come to me
and volunteer his story it took me a
year and a half of dealing with him
before he would finally begin to tell me
his story he had to really trust me
first and decide that you know that I
could be trusted to deal with this and
you know how did somebody plant him
there and have him you know go on for a
year and a half without telling me the
story if this was all part of a plot to
deceive me it's you know it's pretty
damn well done I'll say that if the plot
was done and finally I get to the point
where the coincidences are so
extraordinary that to explain them away
the conspiracy theory has to be bigger
than the real conspiracy and finally you
get to a point you say I believe it the
author of the book is Gary sick the
title is October Surprise thank you for
joining us so a great pleasure